let's optimize some javascript
hey today we're going to be doing a deep
dive on optimizing a chunk of javascript
code
specifically i have a fairly unoptimized
class that we've built up
in a previous tutorial we left a lot of
performance on the table
in the interest of making it easy to
understand and readable
today we're walking through and i'll be
showing you how to profile and optimize
this
ending up with something significantly
faster
now whether you're interested in game
specific optimization or just general
javascript optimization
i think you'll learn and pick up a few
tips today anyway
so leading off from the last tutorial we
covered the basic
implementation of a spatial hash grid
which can be super useful in game
situations
and given it's such a simple and easy
data structure to implement
it lends itself really well to profiling
and optimization
before we go make sure you're subscribed
so you don't miss out on future videos
so let's get started my rough strategy
is to start with some high level
questions about the code and
gradually refine them usually you start
with some questions like
is this whatever it is is it having a
real tangible effect
on your code is this actually important
to spend time optimizing
i'm not usually the type to start
optimizing something right away so you
need to prove that it's a problem first
next you want to try and isolate the
code you're optimizing into a benchmark
of some sort or
at least a reproducible situation to
create a baseline to optimize against
in games this might either be by
actually creating a real benchmark by
running the code in an isolated
situation
or by using a scenario that's at least
consistent in our case i created a
synthetic little benchmark comparing the
results of thousands of find nearby
or update calls after that you want to
examine the code in question and ask
some general questions
things like can this code run
realistically faster
if so and if the stars were aligned the
moon's in the right position
whatever roughly how fast could it go
what's the upper bound here
the speed of light the fastest you can
go without resorting to magic
this is an important question because
there's an absolute bottom line of work
that a bit of code has to do
despite any and all optimizations and if
you estimate that things still won't go
fast enough
it's time to step back and think about
optimizing at a higher level
the example that's usually thrown around
is that one pregnant woman can produce a
baby in roughly nine months
but nine pregnant women can't produce a
baby in one month
let's dive into the code the very first
thing i'm going to do is take the
original spatial grid
slow class and copy paste it into a new
class
the reason is that i want to be able to
do a b tests and compare the performance
directly between the old and new code
giving the exact same inputs
now that's out of the way let's take a
quick tour of the benchmark code
there's not much to explain here other
than we generate a bunch of client data
and we use this grid tester class to
batch a large number of calls to find
nearby or update
let's make sure there's actually enough
work to profile so let's bump up the
numbers to like 10 000
meaning we'll do 10 000 queries per
benchmark run
this is just to make it easier to gauge
the results of profiling
next we'll grab a profile so if you
didn't know chrome has a built-in
profiler
you just need to bring up devtools so
you just go press this little icon here
i think it's called a hamburger icon
i'm not sure go to more tools and then
you can open up developer tools
you can also just press ctrl shift c to
bring it up with a keyboard shortcut
you should see a bunch of tabs here
we're going to use the performance tab
so i'll just click on that
at first it's pretty empty we have to
actually record a profile
there's two buttons to take profiles
there's the record button which just
sort of starts profiling right away
the other is a bit of a convenience one
what it does is starts profiling and
then reloads the page for you
and i'll use that since the benchmark i
wrote just runs as soon as the page
loads
so after you press the button here i
just need to wait a few seconds and then
i can hit stop
it'll process things for a second and
then you'll get this timeline view of
the main thread as well as other threads
and you can see the dependencies
and ipc's between processes if you press
the sources tab you'll get this cool
breakdown of how much time was
attributed to individual lines
of code which is mostly what i'll be
using today so let's kind of browse
through a bit
and we can roughly see where time is
getting spent there's a little bit of
time getting lost in some unnecessary
stuff like destructuring like on these
lines we're spending a bit of time here
and there but
overall it's pretty obvious that we're
sinking most of our time into the big
calls
i don't really like killing these tiny
things anyway because they make things
nice and readable which is important
because
when there's bigger fish to fry trying
to go after these is really scraping the
bottom of the barrel
there's a time and place for those kind
of micro optimizations but
it's not now anyway let's take a deeper
look at a few of these lines
specifically client.add and delete and
we should understand what these are and
why they're slow
the clients and cells these are either
set containers or map containers
both of which are depending on the
implementation going to be order log n
or order one time complexity for things
like access
so reasonably fast a couple observations
right off the bat
we're taking a ton of time in just a few
spots those being the
set add and deletes now there's two
major hot spots the first isn't find
nearby where the results is a set
you can see it's declared down here and
we add to it over on this line
now the reason for this is simple units
can be inserted into multiple cells
recall back to the first video if you
have a large unit that spans multiple
cells
it gets inserted into multiple cells
which is simple enough
but it has this side effect that when
you retrieve the client from multiple
cells
there's a chance of duplicates the
strength of a set container is that it
guarantees that all the elements in the
container are unique which
in this case is great because that means
we can just add every client from every
cell and the set will take care of
making sure that we don't have any
duplicates
but there's a slight downside in that
it's not as fast as it could be which is
pretty obvious from the profile
internally the set container will be
implemented either with some sort of
tree or
hash table meaning operations will be
subliner
if it's a tree it's probably a red black
tree and so insertion will be something
like order log n
and if it's a hash table then insertion
will be amortized
order one this is a long way of saying
they're fast
but when you're doing these calls
hundreds or thousands of times per frame
they're not fast enough so what is fast
enough or i guess the better question is
if we wanted to do this as fast as
possible
what would it look like well fast as
possible assuming we still want to put
together a list to be returned
would be to return an array the only
problem is that we still need to
de-duplicate
the items in there so we don't return
the same client multiple times
a set was kind of overkilled to do this
because we know that each client is
uniquely allocated anyway
meaning whoever calls new client expects
to get a brand new unique client
every single call so we're going to make
some small changes here so that we can
ensure that we get no duplicates in the
list
but at almost zero cost so what we can
do is scroll up to new client
and make a small change to the client
definition
what we're doing in here is we're adding
a new field called query id and we're
going to default this to negative 1 to
start
next we need to go up to the constructor
and declare a new member property
we're calling it this dot query ids and
just initialize it to 0 to begin with
we're going to be using this to
deduplicate clients and define nearby
functions so let's scroll down there and
put it to use
the first thing we'll do is change the
result set into an array
since appending to an array is about as
cheap as it gets
and we're going to be using the query id
property that we just added to remove
duplicates
next we're going to increment the query
id right here before the main loop
this ensures that the query id we're
using in this call is unique
then while we're iterating the list of
clients within in individual cell
what we can do is check the client's
query id versus the current query id
if it's different it means that we
haven't seen this client yet so go ahead
and add it to the results array
by the way since the results array isn't
the set anymore we need to switch from
add to push
then we need to make sure to set this
client's query id to the current query
id
and that means if it turns up in another
cell this if statement will fail
and it won't be added to the list and so
we're good
this little change gets rid of the set
container we were using for the results
and let's compare the performance and
we're seeing a considerable improvement
here
the slow grid fine nearby calls took
roughly around 107 milliseconds or so
but
the new improved one only took about 44.
looks like it's roughly two times faster
but there's still a lot of low-hanging
fruit in the function
so let's go back first thing we can do
is take a new profile
so go ahead and press the second
profiling button here which starts
profiling and reloads the page
a few seconds should be good and then we
can stop the capture and take a look i'm
going to go straight to the source tab
this time since i want to see how hot
spots in find nearby changed
we're still losing a lot of time in here
and the biggest thing to notice
is that a lot of it is just going to
iterating over the values in the cell
and checking if the cell even exists
those two add up to quite a few
milliseconds and there's not a whole lot
of reason for this
to check to see if the cell exists is
just because we lazily created them
if we didn't lazily create each cell
we'd know for certain it
exists and iterating the values in the
set well that's never going to be as
cheap as iterating a linked list or an
array
there's not a whole lot we can do
without fundamentally changing the data
structure we're using
to go as fast as possible you want a
simple data structure here
the choices being either a link list or
some sort of array
now in this particular case of just
iterating the elements of the cell
both of these choices work so you
probably go with array since it's almost
certainly faster
but data structure changes have a more
global effect on the class
so we need to see how the insert and
remove function would be affected
given the choice of either data
structure so let's
look at insert first this is pretty
simple
it gets the bounds of a client iterates
all cells that overlap it and inserts
the client into that cell
so either data structure works here you
can trivially push to an array or a
linked list
nothing complicated about that so let's
move on in the remove function we do a
similar looping through all cells but
there's
a small gotcha here in any given cell we
need to remove the client
previously these were set containers
which can do a lookup and find the item
you're trying to delete in order login
or even order one time
but if we change this into something
other than a set we need some way of
deleting elements quickly
finding and deleting a specific element
from an array or
linked list for example is order n it's
slow as dirt
but there's a couple tricks here we can
use that can speed things up
considerably
with an array finding an item is the
bottleneck but if you already know the
index of an item
under certain conditions this can be
extremely fast
consider this array you could imagine
these are items in your world
for example and say here at this index
you want to remove this guy here
normally when you think of removing an
item from an array
you have to do a somewhat complicated
bit of surgery to the array
you take the item out then you go and
shift everything left by one so that
everything is back in the same order
no gaps or anything just missing the
item you wanted removed
but here's where you can make it faster
if you don't give a crap about the order
of the items
instead of shifting everything over you
can simply swap the item with the last
item in the list and then pop it off the
end
job done barely takes any time at all
similarly for a linked list
finding the item is the bottleneck but
given a node in a list
removing it is trivial let's use a
doubly linked list
as an example you've got your pointers
to the previous to next items in the
chain
so removing an item is as simple as
modifying the previous item in the chain
and pointing it past you to the next
item and then doing the same for the
next item in the chain just pointing it
to the one behind you
at that point the item you wanted
removed isn't referenced anywhere
effectively removing it from the list
back to the code
so how does this help us in the context
of this delete function
it means that if the client had carried
some extra information about exactly
where it was in the list for any given
cell
this delete function would be trivial
you might be able to get an
array to work here but i'm going to go
with a doubly linked list for simplicity
so what we'll do is we'll need to make a
handful of small changes throughout the
class to change everything to use a
doubly linked list
starting with the constructor we're not
going to allocate a single map anymore
instead we're going to allocate a
two-dimensional array of nodes
each one corresponding to a cell and of
course since we haven't inserted
anything into the grid yet
each cell will be initialized to null
this will take care of having to do any
kind of checks to see whether or not a
cell exists
before we access it since they all exist
even they're
just null it's a bit of a trade-off
using a bit more memory
so you can decide if it's the way you
want to go now a new client i'm going to
change things a bit in the client dict
instead of the indices we're going to
store a few more things
i'll change this to a full-on subject
calling it cells
and it'll store the indices of the cells
this client has been inserted into
which isn't much different than before
we'll also add this new field called
nodes and what this is going to do
is for any given cell we can access the
linked list node that was created to
insert this client
okay so the initialization is out of the
way we just need to make some
modifications to find nearby
insert and delete to support the new
linked list
starting with find nearby the old code
used to use the xy
cell indices to create a hash string to
access the cells map
but we can just use x and y directly to
access the head node for that cell
at that point it's just a simple matter
of iterating the linked list
so while head is defined we can access
the client from the node's client
property
and then we assign head to next the
inner part of this loop is identical to
the old version where we check the query
id and then insert it into the results
array let's scroll down to the insert
function now
this changes a little bit more the first
thing is that since
insert is what's called to actually
insert the client into each cell
we want to track the nodes so we declare
that at the top here and in the first
iteration of the x-axis
we just insert another array making it
two-dimensional
now in the inner loop this used to be a
simple add call
but we're going to have to do a bit more
work now we define a dict called head
which is a node in the doubly linked
list and default the previous next
pointers to null
at that point we insert it into the
nodes array which is going to get saved
on the client
then we're going to set head.next to
equal to the head of the cells linked
list
effectively making this the new head of
the linked list
so you just set the current cell's
previous node to head and then you set
the cell to point ahead
at the end of the function we just need
to do a little maintenance on the
client so we need to fill out the cell
stick with indices and nodes
so that's all we're doing here okay last
up we need to modify the remove function
so let's take a look in here
this was a relatively bare bones
function before since the
set's delete function took care of
everything for us
in the inner loop we need to make a
bunch of modifications
basically doing the doubly linked list
removal for ourselves
so the first thing you want to do is get
a reference to the linked list node
and we save that back in the insert
function you just need to access the
client.cells.nodes with the proper
indices
removing from a doubly linked list is as
simple as inserting so what you need to
do is look at the next node in the list
and if it exists you have it reference
the previous item in the chain
same with the previous item you need to
check that exists and if it does
assign its next to the next item in the
list
lastly there's one final check that
needs to be done and that's of you
deleting the head node because it's
referenced by this dot
cells at x and y so if you're deleting
the head node just make sure you update
the reference there to point at the next
one in the list
and that's it we're done it was a little
involved but if you're familiar with
linked lists there should have been a
breeze
let's test the performance out so i
won't bother with a profile and i'll
just reload and let's check out the
numbers
the first thing that pops out is the
find near calls appear to be slightly
slower but that's not too unexpected
the major difference in find nearby is
the use of a linked list instead of the
built-in set type so i could believe
there's some heavy duty optimization on
v8's end of things to make the set
container as fast as possible
faster than iterating our own hand
rolled link list
the real changes come from the insert
delete functions that's quite a bit
faster
the time difference here is massive
around two and a half to three times
faster so this is really substantial
depending on the game and the usage
patterns this trade-off is probably
easily worth it and there's still room
for more improvement and easy wins in
there
back in the code let's scroll over to
the update function
this is implemented in a super simple
way we simply remove the item from the
grid
and then we reinsert it now you can try
and do something more complicated like
figure out which indices it used to be
in
and which ones it should be in now and
do a difference on the two
but let's think about the problem a bit
let's start with a basic rectangular
world so i'll just draw a super crappy
one
and then let's just throw some random
crap in there real quick so i'll add
some people and monsters and whatever
else
you can just endure me drawing some
stuff so if i overlay a grid on top
and now let's think about what's
happening in any given frame
the game is likely to be running at
something like 30 fps
minimum meaning you get about 1 30th of
a second to do anything like movement
and whatever else
now even if you're using small cells 1
30th of a second
isn't a whole lot of time if this guy is
walking across the field
they'll barely make it anywhere in any
given frame update
chances are that a few units will cross
cell boundaries but in reality most will
just be in a slightly different spot in
the same grid cell they were in before
basically we can expect a lot of
temporal coherence between frames
everything is mostly going to be in the
same place it was in the previous frame
back in the code that means that we
shouldn't reasonably expect that a given
client will move far enough to trigger a
full removal slash insert
in fact we can build in a check to see
whether or not this has happened
so we look at the cell's indices this
unit overlaps with and check whether or
not they're
the exact same ones that are stored in
the client we store the min max indices
so you're just doing four equality
checks here and if they're all the same
we can early out and return from the
function
let's test out the performance here
which just means reloading the page
and the numbers are super promising
again no need to look at the fine nearby
numbers since there's no relevant
changes there
but look at the update numbers now these
are awesome down to just 20 milliseconds
or so at least in this synthetic
benchmark
this is roughly 15 times faster than the
original implementation
and five times faster than the improved
faster one
now our synthetic benchmark only allowed
a small bit of movement to kind of
simulate an
individual unit moving around on a map
but depending on the size of your cells
or how fast or frequently things move
around you may be hitting that slower
remove
insert path more often so both
optimizations could be necessary
for fun we can take a quick profile so i
just head over to the performance tab
clear out the existing profile and hit
the reload button
i want to capture a solid couple seconds
of time before hitting stop and then i
can poke around
there's always more things you can do
like in this case i'm scrolling through
the graph here
and you can see there's quite a few gcs
or garbage collections being triggered
there may be some wins to be had by
creating our own allocators and reusing
objects heavily
i can also go poke around in the sources
tab to see what else is available
but in reality here's where we can kind
of leave things i just wanted to give
you a step-by-step
idea of what i might do when i'm
profiling and we've been able to take
this initial spatial grid implementation
and make it considerably faster given
just a few half-assed passes
to make it do less stupid things hope
you enjoyed this and learned something
in the process
code should all be up on the github like
i sometimes remember to do
let me know what you thought in the
comments also remember to like and
subscribe
and until next time cheers